d'accord on ne bouge pas pendant le
single on ne bouge pas pendant le single
on ne bouge pas alors une gueule voilà
non mais je sais mais je n'avais pas
fini mais je me la finir maintenant
c'est par souci non mais je me disais un
problème de ravaillac un ravaillac 2000
par exemple si l'arrivée et qui vous
tuer thierry mois serait bien à la mer
sera jamais pourquoi on ne bouge pas
voir en bas qui a essayé tout laurent
baffie notoriété là on va fier a fait 6
et de ci de là et c est pourquoi pour
qui et on ne l'a jamais dit pour mes
reins bouge pas et voilà on ne saura
jamais j'emporterai de secret dans ma
tombe comme l'endroit de mal parce qu'on
n'a qu'une vie bah oui mais moi personne
du soir non en fait je veux dire la
vérité rien il ya le secret est enfermé
dans mon coffre à la banque dans une
enveloppe scellée qu'on ouvrira à ma
mort
alors il fallait que tu meures alors
une chaleur sont en même temps c'est
pour rigoler avec le public n'obéit qu'à
moi vous avez des vannes criantes aussi
bien est ce que le fait que pour moi
c'est non mais je n'allais pas énervé
que vos parents sont blancs et que les
votes sont noirs et ça vous fait rigoler
c'est un mensonge
ah oui il faut dire quand ces vues faut
dire non à ces interviews mensonge c'est
à dire le contraire de la vérité
oui et vous ils sont noirs c'est évident
mais c'est ridicule est il un vrai que
lorsque alain de greef vous a vu pour la
première fois elle nous a pas reconnus
qui nous a pas reconnus côté vous avez
pour la première fois mais c'est normal
enfin c'est pas normal
[Rires]
par contre à vous avez exigé quoi dans
votre contrat avec canal+ nous ce qu'on
exigeait un parce que on s'en occupe pas
en fait un tel mensonge et de votre
bureau vous avez quoi à cana tectonique
des plaques c'est à dire que c'est la
faille de san andreas est intéressant
parce que la tectonique des plaques on
n'en parle pas assez et ça se frotte
comme ça et hop la faille passe par
canal exactement où les scores les
vacances vous les prenez au mensonge
toujours ou pas ah ouais ah c'est mon
souhait parce que moi je reste chez moi
le calcul des corrections de ne rien
rater de leonard itunes
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux